να απόδοση αγαπετε σωστά στά άρα όλα είναι αποτελέσματα αποτελέσματα τα πάντ ναι πολύ καλοβιογραφικό
εξαιρετικό ο ένα στις δερεύνεσης ο άλος τις ο επιρι διακών ικανωτήτον απο τελέσματα όμως
έχουμε α ποτελέσματα να δούμε να θα έσει απο τελέσματα ετ τα όλα απογίνετας τελευταίς
τα τον δύο μήνες διαθεσημόητα στυνομικών ου εκάμαγκάτι βλέπουμε πιο πολλές επιχειρήσεις εξαναυκήκα στους δρόμους
θα ξεχάσω το θέμα με το ότι επεθάναν κάποια μορκάποιοι νεαρή για να ξαναυκούν έξω
για στυνομικί να κάνουν άλκο της ωραία ολα αυτά μόνος σας έχετεχωρήσει χωρίς να τοθετ
σε τρεις τομείς αυτά απου πρέπει να γίνουν την ίδιανημερα που την ημέρα μονάλαβα τα
βράρχει πρόθεσμα που θέλουν κάποιο εξι εφτά οκτώ ένα χρόνουν αλλάξουν στην αστυνομία και να
μακροπρόθεσμα τουτά τα τρία όμως πρέπει να φκανεις και να ανημερώνεις τον κόσμο και τους
αστυνομικούς γιατί κάποια πράγματα αφορούν τους αστυνομικούς κάποιο αφορούν και τους πολίτες τουτα πρέπει να
γίνούν τι επικράτησε στην αστυνομία τους τελευταίος τές σερις μήνες ου αλλά ενηγεσία εγώ θα
το πω δεν έχω εκάνε να θέμα να μετωε επικρατεί μία ανήσυχη ειρεμία η ανήσυχη
είναι γιατί περιμένουμε να δούμε τι αλλά γα θα πράξει η ιρεμία που επικρατε είναι
γιατί μας έδωσεν την εντύπωση που έρχεται κάτω μόνος του πινετα υτοκίνητων και κατεβαίνει με
στους σταθμούς α πρόπτα ο αρχηγός ο υπάρχειεγός κατλεναι πρόπτονε στας υπηρεσίες και κάθεται μαζίμους
αστυνομικούς και μιλά και κάνηςα έδωσε μας στην εντύπωση ότι θέλει θέλει να πατη ήκουμια
ωραία και ξέρει και ακουπια πρέπατήσει υπάρχει αυτή η ειρεμεία γιατί περιμένουμε ναπατεθούντα γονται αλλά
κάποια η εγουνότα που αναφέρεται θορείται ότι βορούν μας που πίσω πρέπει να τρίξουμε πρέπει
να αλλάξουμε γρήγορα πράγματα πρέπειίσως να πρέπει και λίγομε τον προυπολογισμέσ αστυνομίας να δούμε δηλαδή
να ξανακρατήσει τ